this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up guys michael here living
through the pandemic has been terrible
for obvious reasons but especially early
on it was also a time of weird
experimentation with fads like cocktails
and coffee cups jack box marathons and
codependent relationships with sourdough
starters and of course it also
kick-started a new conversation about
working from home prior to the modern
plague only six percent of people worked
remotely that's ballooned to a whopping
42 percent of u.s workers today
including basically all of your friends
here at wisecrack but with everything
opening back up and execs calling for a
return to the office is that about to
change well we have to leave our bed
desks and business sweats behind and do
we lose something when we stop working
in person let's find out in this
wisecrack edition is working from home
here to stay before we get into it i
want to give a quick shout out to this
week's sponsor keeps by now you may have
heard the statistic that two out of
three guys experience male pattern
baldness of some kind by the time they
hit 35 which is
alarming but luckily keeps here to help
it's a subscription service that makes
it easier and more affordable to prevent
hair loss first you'll schedule a free
consultation with a licensed keeps
doctor they can help you get the right
combination of fda approved
prescriptions and over-the-counter
medications to help prevent further hair
loss you can message your keeps doctor
24 7 to update them on your progress or
ask them questions your automatic
refills are shipped to your door every
three months so you don't have to worry
about running out of medication and you
can skip trips to the pharmacy keeps has
more 5 star reviews than any of its
competitors get started today and you
can see results in four to six months if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com
wisecrack or click the link in the
description to receive 50 off your first
order that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
wisecrack now back to the show there's a
lot of debate about whether working from
home is good or bad in general most
employees prefer to work from home but
there are downsides one study found that
70 of remote professionals work weekends
and 45
work more than they did before the
pandemic all the time we saved on the
commute got funneled straight back into
work this has led to an even blurrier
line between work and life because both
now occupy the same space a lot of
workers are now expected to be
accessible 24 7. that in addition to
missing your work friends and your water
cooler gossip has resulted in a lot of
burned out depressed and dissociated
people trying not to lose their minds in
their living room offices but working
from home isn't all bad for one it saves
everyone money employees don't have to
pay for gas or lunch from panda express
and employers don't have to worry about
office spaces and stocking up on
industrial rolls of toilet paper
although your boss should be paying to
outfit your home office but that's a
story for another day employees are also
more productive than they were
pre-pandemic because they're under less
pressure to look busy and aren't
constantly being interrupted by guys who
won't stop talking about body hacking
for most workers this is reason enough
to keep working at home but odds are
your boss disagrees while most employees
aren't in a hurry to rush back to a
soulless husk of an office building
execs and higher level management are
pushing to get them back in their
cubicles the central argument is that
remote work lacks a certain genesee quoi
jp morgan ceo jamie dimon summed it up
as such it doesn't work for those who
want to hustle it doesn't work for
spontaneous idea generation it doesn't
work for culture which made us wonder is
the in-person office really all it's
cracked up to be do they actually
promote hustle creativity and culture
what are employers seeing that we aren't
diamond's quote reflects a broader
preoccupation among the higher-ups
namely hustle this isn't anything new
executives have been concerned about
their employees performing with gusto
since forever to understand why meet
frederick winslow taylor an early 20th
century mechanical engineer at bethlehem
steel you see season one of the
industrial revolution wasn't the best as
far as attendance and productivity were
concerned early factories were designed
after workhouses and prisons so
understandably no one wanted to be there
plus workers used to the flexibility as
afforded by working on farms or in small
family businesses had never had to clock
in for their boss at nine before now all
of a sudden they had to skip christmas
to shovel coal into a furnace all day
it's christmas day you gave me the day
off would i do a thing like that taylor
observed this and concluded that workers
were inherently lazy his solution
optimization so like a little industrial
gremlin he crawled around the factory
and timed workers with a stopwatch
looking for any wasted movements to
shave off their routines taylor's goal
was to make workers as machine-like as
possible they went from performing
complex processes on their own to only
being responsible for a single step it
was more soul-sucking than making out
with the dementor industrialist henry
ford eventually used taylor's ideas to
maximize productivity via the infamous
ford assembly line taylor found that the
more data he collected and the more
control he had over the process the
better workers performed but to make
this function smoothly he needed a
steady supply of loyal workers committed
to the business hierarchy so he created
the middle manager originally they took
the form of disciplinarians and or gang
bosses as middle managers spread across
the workplace that kept watch fined or
expelled workers for nefarious offenses
such as talking and eating and made sure
all the mind-numbing activities were
done on time or else around the 1930s
people started coming around to the then
novel idea that workers performed better
when they weren't afraid of being
punched in the head middle manager's job
descriptions expanded from maintaining
productivity at all costs to also asking
concerned questions like you hanging in
there this shift created the modern
manager but despite their growing
concern for employee welfare they're not
all warm handshakes and pets on the back
and thanks to taylor there's still a
narrative that workers are innately lazy
and managers continue to fixate on
surveillance as a way of controlling
productivity at the start of the
pandemic use of surveillance software
increased by 50
and continues to rise in spite of
productivity being at an all-time high
the software doesn't just give your
employer the ability to look through
your email and the memes you post on
slack they can control your webcam and
mic take screenshots of your desktop and
monitor your activity down to the
keystroke so you know like big brother
[ __ ] but absolutely real this is a
natural evolution for an american
management system built on not trusting
people to do their jobs and how do you
monitor a big group of people who you
think are lazy babies you schedule a
whole lot of meetings indeed meetings
have increased in length and frequency
over the past 50 years to the extent
that executives on average spend over
half their work week in them this
wouldn't be an issue if meetings were
actually helpful but more often than not
employees report they're unproductive
inefficient and disruptive during the
pandemic managers scheduled even more
meetings it sure seems like what the
anti-work from home crew is missing
isn't work but the optics of doing work
okay so maybe offices and the people who
run them are built on some serious trust
issues but what about the spontaneous
idea generation that's rumored to happen
at the office do we need to be in person
to harness that sweet sweet synergy not
if you ask the people designing our
offices currently 70 to 80 percent of
american offices are open plan while
many attribute this innovative design to
silicon valley tech companies they're
the dirty work of you guessed it our
good friend frederick taylor he arranged
workers in endless rows of desks with
offices lining the outside for managers
to keep watch the open office plan was
hailed as a huge success because it
improved productivity efficiency and
made surveilling your workforce even
easier on the downside it encouraged
noise distractions and tons of animosity
towards the guy chewing a tuna fish
sandwich with his mouth open believe it
or not cubicles were originally designed
as a solution to the chaotic grind of
the open office but through a series of
cost cuts offices quickly devolved into
cubicle farms so companies swerved back
to the open office plan which is
conveniently cheaper because they don't
have to buy any walls and supposedly
more conducive to happy collaboration
but it turns out that open floor plans
have been found to almost universally
increase stress levels heighten blood
pressure as well as cause burnout also
open offices are downright terrible for
spontaneous communication and creativity
surveys find that open offices actually
resulted in 70 percent less face-to-face
communication and use of electronic
messaging increased by 22 to 50 percent
most people just plug in their
headphones blast in bts and do their
best to tune everyone else out and
tuning people out is hard when nobody
has any privacy and where steve in the
sales department has a super loud phone
voice all these interruptions mean less
time for the distraction-free
concentration that actually leads to
good ideas the more companies try to
control creativity the more they
actually snuff it out so why are
executives pushing for this because they
generally don't work in an open office
they have their own private offices with
walls and doors and space and privacy
the office they want to return to is
significantly less shitty than the
office their employees will return to
you'd want to go back to the office too
if you had a private beverage fridge and
assistance to grab your lunch but we
also have to admit that at least for
some of us working from home can be
incredibly isolating it's easy to feel
disconnected from your co-workers and
your company when you only interact with
them through a screen especially when
you find out they were much taller than
you thought maybe going into work is
worth it to preserve company culture but
what even is company culture the idea of
corporate culture was predated by a
period of economic stagnation in the 70s
that gave rise to a historic amount of
downsizing in the 80s and 90s this
resulted in a huge wave of corporate
cynicism as employees realized that
companies no longer had their best
interests at heart organization
consultants terence diehl and alan
kennedy tried to repair this rift
between corporations and employees with
their book the new corporate cultures
they promised that a business could cut
costs stay lean and make their employees
less miserable with company culture
business schools ate this up like it was
thousand dollar caviar more democratic
practices were introduced like treating
employees like responsible adults in
addition to team building events more
cake and parties the company was a
family again that is if your family is
ruthless enough to sh can you while
everyone else is doing goat yoga and as
much as they claim they aren't like
other mega corporations venture
capitalists promoted the exact same
toxic company culture just with
different frosting startups used the
idea that an app could change the world
to encourage obsessive devotion to the
company and to justify the destruction
of any semblance of work-life balance
this isn't just my job
this is my religion even if you don't
work at one of these ipa spewing mega
corporations company culture still sucks
an organization's goal will always be
profit and optimization first employee
health instability second or third or
fourth what's more the company culture
movement hasn't exactly made traditional
office spaces better at being inclusive
after all traditional offices were
specifically designed with the comfort
of usually white male executives in mind
right down to the standardized 68 to 76
degree temperatures because sweaty suits
at the end of the workday company
culture is just an enticing emotional
narrative that makes workers invest more
time and energy into the company it's no
surprise that the main defendants of
company culture are largely the same
executives pushing to go back to the
office because the office has always
worked best for them but much to your
boss's dismay offices probably aren't
going back to the way they used to be or
at least not across the board we might
just be on the brink of an exciting
turning point ongoing remote work is
changing everything even the very shape
of our cities mark miro a senior fellow
and policy director at the brookings
institution noted that remote workers
are moving out of major metropolitan
areas like new york or the bay area to
the suburbs creating a donut-shaped
population density around major cities
workers want to be close enough to
commute to the office a couple days a
week but still gain the financial
benefits of suburban life the influx of
remote workers to suburbs and small
cities is both good and bad on the one
hand remote workers support the local
economy by working out of coffee shops
cafes and other mixed-use spaces on the
other hand the influx of people making
city money snapping up houses in smaller
markets are causing housing prices to
rise at unprecedented rates workers
supported by the local economy are being
priced out of town plus many small
cities and suburbs simply were not built
to hold this many people they don't have
the infrastructure like transportation
and available housing to support the
sudden increase in population this is
contributing to a growing class divide
which remote urban workers were
originally trying to escape speaking of
big metropolitan areas they just a lost
cause cultured journalist charlie
warzone and helen peterson don't think
so they argue that because work in the
office is no longer an incentive to live
in town city officials should work with
urban planners to step up their game
large office buildings can be
transformed into multi-use spaces cities
may shift from giving tax subsidies for
new factories and warehouses to
investing in schools parks and the arts
to encourage residents to stick around
it could also mean investing in street
dining better transit improved
walkability and more flexible workspaces
for people who don't want to work at
home or the office in essence cities may
move from appeasing job makers to
greasing the palms of the people
actually doing the work but no matter
where we are we still have a long way to
go in negotiating our boundaries with
work as we become more spatially
decentralized from the office maybe it's
time to make work more decentralized
from our lives but what do you guys
think what if work wasn't the center of
our lives and homes could working
remotely be the key to escaping our
corporate overlords and real pants once
and for all let us know what you think
in the comments big thanks to all our
patrons and be sure to check out our new
patreon features hit that subscribe
button like you're punching sign out on
your time card and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you